since the last time I saw you you became
a dad yeah I I think I heard oh and I
saw with last time I was here we were
pregnant yes but just my wife was but by
proxy I was but yeah so we you know I
have a two-year-old and change daughter
and yes it's great yeah I I had my kids
I don't know we're probably roughly the
same age and I had my kids somebody left
at that only we are really the same age
well I'll say I'm 56 years old yeah yeah
you that's why you don't see me in those
teen magazines anymore
but but you know so and my kids are
teenagers now you're now having the
experience of being like a little bit of
an older dad with a young kid sure yeah
and and it's a this is for real
literally the day I flew I flew out here
on Monday night and that day I had taken
my daughter to playground park in in
Brooklyn where we live and I was we were
getting ready to leave and she was kind
of being fussy and I was like come on
don't you want to see mommy and ollie
and Ollie is our dog and she was being a
little difficult and I was taking her in
the stroller and there's a woman on a
bench who was just trying to be engaging
and friendly chitchat and she you know
because he was being fussy and and she
looked up but she's like why go home to
mommy when you can have so much fun with
grandpa yeah it did it took me I was
like three steps out of the gate before
I went oh wait a second I'm I'm grandpa
I'm grandpa and I but I do not fault
that I mean I would I get it I get it
I had I guess I was I remembered I was
back home with visiting my family in
Boston and I had my kids with me this is
a bunch of years ago when they were
young kids and they were playing in a
playground in
Austin common and I was hanging out
watching you know my kids play with
other kids and I was watching in this
guide and recognized me and came up and
went hey Conan O'Brien it's like oh yeah
hey how you doing and he hung out there
for a little second I'm just watching he
said do you have any kids in that
playground I said you better hope so
like you know like we're not now I don't
you missed a golden opportunity my
friend I know I didn't think God with it
no oh I will
[Applause]
[Laughter]
well that was controversial